the survivors that were found were
winched to safety in a massive rescue
operation in the middle of the
Mediterranean Sea the Dead were from
Egypt Syria Palestine and Pakistan
they'd gone to Libya first and then
tried to make it into Europe
we collected 104 people that are here at
the harbor at Kalamata in safe places
doctors and nurses have come from the
hospital to examine the immigrants 21 of
them were taken to hospital for
intensive care plus four more that from
the first moment were taken to the
hospital by helicopter because they were
more heavily injured the rescues have
been taken to Mainland Greece they are
being looked after by Aid agencies the
injured have been taken to hospital some
are suffering from hypothermia
we are here offering first aid and
psychological support to those people
who have suffered a very heavy blow both
physical and mental uh
distressed who wouldn't be distressed
after a shipwreck we hope more survivors
will be found from this shipwreck
it's not known how many were on board
but judging by pictures there could have
been hundreds many of them below deck
and out of sight
Greek Coast Guard ships a Navy frigate
helicopters and a military plane are all
searching the area for more survivors
and possibly more bodies
the search will continue overnight but
the ship sank in one of the deepest
parts of the Mediterranean making any
recovery that much harder
the United Nations says that the route
between North Africa and Italy is the
most dangerous migrant Crossing in the
world
17 000 people have died over the past
decade
Sky News recently witnessed hundreds
being rescued trying to cross into
Europe
the weather is good now the Seas
generally calmer and so Smugglers are
taking advantage and more people are
trying to make the crossing whilst they
can
this is already a major disaster and the
death toll is likely to rise further